The
Exploding Anti-Tank Dogs of World War II
During WWII many innovative weapons were created
and promptly put into action.
One of the more unique, and wildly inhumane,
were exploding anti-tank dogs.
These dogs, usually Alsatians, were also called
“Hundminen” or “dog mines.”
They were trained to carry explosives on their
bodies to enemy tanks, where they would then
be detonated.
No, it did not end very well for the dogs
in question.
This type of animal weaponry was first used
by the Soviets.
Following a decision in 1924 to allow dogs
to aid the military, a dog training school
was set up in Moscow.
The military recruited such people as police
dog trainers, hunters, circus trainers, and
animal scientists.
Twelve more schools were set up hot on the
heels of the first one and the Soviet dog-training
division started out in earnest.
At first, dogs were trained to carry supplies,
tracking mines, and rescuing people -tasks
at which the dogs excelled.
In the early 1930s, they decided it would
be a good idea to turn man’s best friend
into an anti-tank weapon.
Three of the schools began training dogs for
this purpose.
First, they were trained to carry a bomb to
a tank and run off; afterwards, their handler
could detonate the bomb with a remote or the
bomb may have simply been set with a timer.
There were several reasons that these methods
didn’t work.
To drop the bomb, the dogs had to pull on
a belt with their teeth to release it.
This proved to be too complicated, and often
the dog would simply return to its handler
without releasing the bomb.
Secondly, remotes were too expensive at the
time to be used practically, so timers would
be used more often instead.
If the dog returned to his handler with the
bomb still attached, he would have killed
the handler and himself.
Even if the bomb was released under the tank,
if the tank was in motion and the timing wasn’t
set just so, the bomb would simply explode
without doing any damage to the enemy tank.
The Soviets scrapped their initial plan, but
unfortunately for Fido, they came up with
a new one.
Rather than drop a bomb, explosives would
be strapped to the dog.
When the dog went under the tank, the bomb
would be triggered, killing the dog (and,
hopefully, disabling the tank).
As if ending their life wasn’t enough, the
training involved wasn’t exactly a walk
in the park.
The dogs were starved, and then food was placed
under a practice tank, training them to think
that food was under all tanks.
After a while, additional battle sounds were
added to their practice runs so that they
wouldn’t be spooked when they were running
under the real thing.
Anti-tank dogs started being used in earnest
in 1941, when German forces advanced on Soviet
lands.
Thirty dogs kicked off what would be a rather
lacklustre debut for the exploding dog-force;
indeed, the dogs were so ineffective that
the Soviet military was accused of simply
sacrificing them.
Part of the problem was that many of the dogs
refused to dive under the tanks in the field.
They were being shot at, which hadn’t happened
in training, and they were understandably
not willing to dive under some huge noisy
“beast” that was seemingly trying to kill
them.
Food can only motivate an animal so much.
I could put a steak on my vacuum cleaner and
my dog wouldn’t go near it, even if she
hadn’t eaten in ages.
A tank with guns a-blazing is a tad more noisy
and frightening.
When the dogs were shot and killed before
they could get into position and blow up,
they were taken by German soldiers who were
able to examine the weaponry and potentially
copy it themselves.
They didn’t end up taking advantage; rather,
one captured German soldier claimed that they
found the entire system rather inefficient.
Well, it was.
One downside of this was that the Germans
did take measures to defend themselves against
the dogs, rendering their sacrifice often
useless.
A much larger problem was that the dogs had
been trained with Soviet tanks, not German
ones.
Soviet and German tanks used different types
of fuel, and some of the dogs sniffed out
the fuel they were used to and trotted off
to blow up the tanks used by the very military
that trained them.
Oops.
That said, the anti-tank dogs are known to
have taken out some tanks, including at the
Battle of Kursk in which twelve tanks were
destroyed by sixteen deployed dogs.
This was possibly one of the most successful
anti-tank dog ventures in history.
The Soviets later reported that some 300 tanks
total had been destroyed by anti-tank dogs,
but many question this number, thinking it
was probably made up by the Soviet government
who wanted to justify the program, particularly
justify killing so many dogs with so few results.
Whether they were useful or not, anti-tank
dogs started to be used less and less from
1942 onwards, though there were anti-tank
dogs that continued to be trained until 1996.
While the Soviets were perhaps the most prominent
users of anti-tank dogs, they were trained
in other countries, too, including Japan and
the United States.
Much more recently, bombs were strapped to
dogs as late as 2007 when insurgents attempted
to use them during the Iraq War.
In this case, there’s only one documented
case of a bomb actually being detonated while
attached to a dog though; protests rose up
among Muslims who believe that animals should
be killed only for food.
Bonus Facts:
• Dogs were not the only weaponized animals.
There were attempts to make bomb carriers
out of cats, birds, and rats.
Bombs have also been strapped to camels, horses,
donkeys, and mules.
Donkeys were especially favoured in Iraq because
they could carry packs stuffed with bombs
without looking suspicious.
Even monkeys and, supposedly, whales could
not escape the military’s explosive reach.
• Dolphins trained to kill by the Soviet
Union were sold to Iran in the 1990s when
the Russian military closed its marine mammal
program.
The United States Navy still has such a program,
though dolphins are supposedly not trained
to kill, but rather to perform various
other tasks.